[Music]
on today's show we talk about what comes
next we talked to a woman who's trying
to adjust her friend group to deal with
her new world we talked to a guy who
just sold his business for seven figures
and he wants to know
oh no what do i do now stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
what is
up one foot in and one foot back
they don't pay to live like that this is
a dr john deloney's show still putting
on my headphones
usually i just go right in and i had him
on the wrong ears
so i thought i'd just sing us in today i
hope you're doing great and i hope you
think better than i do for god's sakes
but this show's about mental health
relationships it's your first time
joining us
i'm so glad you're here and if this is
your 17th time joining us
there's a whole bunch of other podcasts
you could be listening to but i'm glad
you're back and i'm glad you keep coming
hey
send your favorite episode to a friend
we've crossed some major milestones that
the numbers are so silly and i can't
wrap my head around them
and i officially can no longer say we
only have 17 people because now we are
good grief man but let's keep it going
i'm this is starting to get fun for me
and starting to get fun we're a year
plus in it's been miserable but now
now it's fun for me
and
man send us a favorite show to somebody
that you care about or more importantly
to someone you're like i think you
should listen to this because it's about
you if you want to be on this show we
talk about mental health relationships
parenting education i don't school you
call about your physical health i don't
know much about it but i'll i'll give it
i'll give it my best shot i don't charge
anything
uh
call one eight four
1-844-693-3291 leave a message
um
leave a long detailed message kelly
likes to listen to these messages she
likes when they're in the three to five
minute range
um
long long ones and or you can email and
or see what i did there john delaney.com
ask make sure while you're on that page
get the newsletter man we send you all
kind of fun stuff on the newsletter
secrets and
that's so awesome
we've never sent a single secret out on
the newsletter but officially i'm
writing a note we're gonna start sending
out
secrets
i don't really know what kind of secrets
we would have and keep writing me your
letters man that's so fun send snail
mail letters
to our address here you've got to know
how the internets work or
can you still call 4-1-1
and get phone numbers
we should try it we'll try it
i'll try it during this and report back
to you excellent don't do that just
google where's the ramsey solutions
building and you can get my mailing
address there but i love getting mail
it's making some of my colleagues
jealous and it cheers me up all right
let's go to lydia in seattle washington
what's up lydia how are we doing
i'm doing good how are you john good i'm
kind of a mess today
i'm getting there
you're gonna be on the show that people
are like what is that guy
doing i'm not drinking it's too early in
the morning but
i'm a bit of a mess but now i'm all back
in i just took my deep breath we're
re-centered and all that zen what's up
lydia
i need to do that too i'm nervous i'm
trying to tell myself i'm just like
talking to a friend oh number one we're
super friends number two
clearly by the first five minutes of
this show i
i don't know what i'm doing so you do
not have anything to be nervous about at
all i'm kind of nervous to talk to you
okay we're from seattle okay so what's
up let's do this
um nothing i've just kind of been
feeling
well okay i'm 26 married i have three
kids um
my husband's my best friend and we have
a great group of friends i want to
preface that i love my group of friends
that i have
um
i just would also like some
new friends i guess like maybe people
that i connect with in other ways
and it's just i gave you my background
because it's kind of
i guess hard to make friends
like i don't know
where or how or
you know with
i guess the group of friends that i have
um
they've just we've been friends with
them for a long time a lot of the girls
that i am friends with are you know
significant others of my husband's
friends and just because we've been
together you know since we were like 18
it's just who i've been surrounded by
and i think now my kids are getting
you know in like the toddler phase so i
can't i have more flexibility to you
know
go out and do stuff on my own or
you know like
i don't
i
hey here's what you're allowed to say
number one
what you're articulating is so hard and
i get that
i get that
and
you're allowed to say
i don't like my husband's friends that
much or you're allowed to say
i
they're default friends like they're
just my friends because they're always
there and so what's up and then suddenly
our kids are playing with their kids and
i don't like how they talk to their kids
their kids are weird or gross or they
don't
and all that starts to add up especially
you've got three kids and i imagine at
26 you're in kind of an uh
little sliver of life where
not a lot of 26 year olds have the
stress of three kids they still have
their special doodle dog and their one
kid
and they're like oh my gosh it's so much
and you're looking at them like how
about i burn your house down or people
with 30 with three kids
are like 40 or they're 35 and they're
like oh yeah you're so cute and they pat
you on the head and you're like listen
yeah i got three kids too idiot
and yeah your husband's right bro let's
just have cheetos and burritos and let's
go get em and by the way cheetos and
burritos rhymed and i've never done that
before until just now
so you find yourself lydia on an island
all by yourself is that fair
yeah yes and no i think my husband even
feels it too like these are people he's
been friends with for a long time but he
has different interests so we feel it on
like two different levels we are both
feeling this personally and we're also
feeling it as a couple okay so that's
actually
that's awesome because y'all are in this
together now
because i've had experiences where
wife wants to break up with friend group
and husband's like what's wrong they're
they're my bros and she's like you're an
idiot yeah and they're okay so let me
ask you a hard question
why don't y'all
start doing other things together and
inviting new different people
well i guess it's just kind of like who
you know like we have i think we need to
like overall meet new people
yes so
yeah so it's just kind of like i guess
we just need to
go out and try new things and just
hopefully meet people that's just
intimidating and like
hard yes
so do either of y'all work
yeah we both work do either of you
like
do things in the community like have a
softball team or uh i don't know like
like a i don't know a club of some sort
or anything like that
no and that's kind of what i've been
thinking about too i think we need to
get out and you know start doing things
in the community and also what i was
thinking too our kids are getting older
you know like they're going to start
playing sports and
or like
music or dance or something like that so
he actually told me about the other day
he's like you know you'll probably meet
like other moms and you know people that
you might have in common so
and what i would say is yes and
and yes and is
you'll be around them it will still be
awkward it'll still be weird one of you
will still have to say hey i'd love to
get together
one of you will have to say hey you and
your husband come over to my house bring
your kids and he's like well i got a
seven-year-old then a two-year-old and
then
we had this
magical one-year-old now that we didn't
plan i mean that will happen and you'll
be like i don't care come over and i'm
not cleaning my house by the way because
this is just how we roll this is the
kind of friends i want to have that i
don't have to clean my house for
and you all get to decide that so if you
are gonna be around people and they'll
be like uh you know preschool kids or
kindergarten kids that you know hey i
want to have three
dads and moms over and their little kid
yeah all that is super true so what i
would tell you is you're at a natural
transition point where this is about to
start happening
and it is uncomfortable i'll just like i
experience it with my my closest friends
all of a sudden you don't think it's
like mean to your current friends like i
don't want to it's not like i don't want
to be friends with them like i feel like
guilty in a way sort of yeah no no not
at all i get what you're saying but not
at all people just grow and things
change and they morph and
what ends up happening is you end up
drowning yourself in your own
expectations and your own guilt
yeah and that guilt turns to resentment
so choose guilt every time it's okay to
feel guilty but you're not breaking up
with anybody
and it's okay to grow and to want new
things especially
when you're doing it in concert with
your partner with your husband there
yeah y'all are doing this together and
so there will still be the once a year
that you get together with all the old
idiots that's cool
um and that once a year or maybe twice a
year becomes once a year and then it
becomes hey we're gonna go do this thing
i experienced this
when
two of my best friends in the world we
all started having kids
and then suddenly
one of my best buddies became like i'm
all in little league person
like i think about little league that's
all i talk about i think about it i'm
like planning strategies for little
league i go to the ball fields on
saturday mornings and i go like i live
there all day i watch the other kids i'm
scouting the other seven year olds
and
then i've got one buddy who became like
a uh
cub scout dad
i was like what i
and yeah like we just have different
interests and then i was like a
idiot dad i want to go play in the woods
all the time and they were like deloney
how here's this cool thing called the
21st century why don't you live in that
and i'm like i know but what if we right
and so
i love them
like love these guys i love their wives
they're close
and we all just kind of naturally
started doing things that were of
interest to us and our particular kids
and our families
and so we get together once a year and
now i live in a different state and all
that we get together once a year but i i
don't begrudge the fact that man he
loves to go to the ball fields all day
that's kind of their thing that's not me
and my kids thing me and my kids thing
is to go play in the mud and go in the
creeks and go hunting a lot
and they're not big hunters that's
awesome so that naturally happens
what's not okay
is if i start
not liking them because life is gently
nudging them in other directions if i
begrudge them then they're not really my
friends i'm trying to hold them into a
picture of what i want our friendship to
be
and the same thing applies for you okay
you'll have three kids you all start
leaning other directions you start
hanging out and then your friend's like
oh my gosh you abandon us you never hang
out with it
well then they're actually yeah that's
what it they're acting like
four-year-olds don't they're not they
can't trap you like that
okay um
and
you have to be intentional about finding
new community because you're gonna get
really lonely
yeah and it's awesome to be married to
your best friend that's the best way to
do it and you still have to have other
people that are just yours
okay because y'all will pull each other
underwater
i talked to too many
executives across the country who use
their spouses as trash cans
here's all the crap that happened to me
today because the only other human they
interact with all day
and that's it i mean
my husband he is my best friend and we
genuinely we love doing things together
we just you know there's certain things
where we want to do you know with
a group me a girlfriend and him and you
know another guy
absolutely absolutely
i want to free you from any burden you
feel that you are stuck in this thing
forever you're not okay
yeah i think i just needed someone to
tell me it's okay you know to like try
to go make other friends without
offending
the ones that we have now not only is it
okay
it's the right healthy loving wonderful
great thing to do
not only is it the right wonderful i
don't remember all those words i just
used not only is it important
but your marriage depends on it
your parenting depends on it
so think of it as we have to start
exercising or we have to start eating
right or we have to
have some sort of faith context in our
life we have to be on the same page with
parenting think of it that and we have
to go to work and earn money so we can
eat think of it it's that important that
we have to create new friendships and
here's the words i want you to hang on
to i want you to
choose guilt over resentment have you
ever heard me say that
no okay
choose guilt
if somebody asks you
hey we want you to hey we're all getting
together to do this thing and your first
thought is i don't want to go hang out
with y'all
you will feel guilty for not going those
first few times you say no yeah you will
feel guilty when they call you like what
we miss you why didn't you come you
never hang ellis anymore and you're like
yeah we're just spending some family
time or we were hanging out with some
friends from someone's from zoe's dance
class
you'll feel guilty and that's normal
that's fine
choose that every time over choosing
resentment and that is you don't want to
go your husband doesn't want to go you
don't want your kids around their kids
but you go anyway because you feel this
yeah that's exactly
and you you you hate getting ready for
it you hate driving over there you hate
being there and then you hate the drive
home and then you and your husband are
whining and complaining to each other
choose guilt every time over resentment
because i feel like the guilt will go
away but the resentment won't the
resentment turns ever it's it's like
coals on a fire it just burns everything
to ash
and it's hard to come back from
resentment and that resentment
breeds
dissension in your marriage and your
kids feel it
and so sometimes i'm like if he doesn't
want to go it's like come on like
let's just go only be there for an hour
or something like that and you want to
do that because you think you're
supposed to that you have a duty to go
no you have a duty to take care of your
family and sleep and laugh and enjoy
this guy you'll have three kids and
you're only 26. if you've got a night
that you can just hang out with your
husband and y'all can look at each other
like you're gross 18 year olds again do
that
don't go hang out with idiots you know
what i mean
you you are right in the right spot
lydia asking the right questions doing
the right things and get some friends
that are older
get like
like me and my wife waited till we were
later to have kids and she hangs out
with lots of people that are five years
younger than her 10 years younger than
her and it's awesome it's super fun
um and i think it's good for the younger
folks to be around someone who's older
and wiser not that i'm saying my wife's
old but she's a thousand
or
it's good for my wife to realize i'm not
so
old i can still hang with i can hang
with the young kids i can hang with the
kids it's good for everybody
you get to exchange wisdom and
excitement and fun and we get to learn
who post malone is i didn't know that
was whatever but cool great question
lydia thank you so much go make new
friends make them all the time always be
making new friends we'll be right back
on dr john elon's show
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot right or if in the
morning your back hurts if you have any
of these issues you may need to check
out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dream cloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer ever 400 bucks in
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for delony listeners
that's a total of about 650 in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
delony or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y good night
all right we are back let's go to larry
in
tallahassee
i just that you have to sing tallahassee
larry
all right uh well no i'm a poor gators
fan and i can't sing so no actually i'm
a grown up and i don't have to sing
tallahassee idiot
thanks larry thanks
thanks for playing along
so what's up dude
i'm much hey thanks for having me on um
i've been wanting to say this for a
while but long time listener first time
caller so super excited to uh to jump on
the phone here with you today dude
nobody ever says that on my show thanks
for thanks for i think you're the first
person to say that thanks man made my
heart feel good
i love being at first um
hey so here i'll jump right into it um
my wife and i sold our business back in
april essentially to our largest
customers at that time
did you all make the killing working
what's that did y'all make a joke do you
make a killing on it did you crush it
yeah yeah it was great it was a
seven-figure exit and we've been ramsey
fans for a long time
congrats man yeah
yeah it was a big big big deal in our
world does uh does millionaire air taste
different than regular personnel
i still drive the same truck i still
drive live in the same house we're the
same clothes and we still bring our
lunch to work so dude you are my hero
man i'm telling you good for you brother
good for you all right so you sold your
business in april you're millionaires
what's up
so we sold the business um
to a very large private equity-owned
company that part of the deal part of
the reason why we were an acquisition
target was because that we fit in with
their their larger
um strategy that they're executing on
over the next several years so
um we sold in april uh we kind of hit
the ground running and now we're we're
six months into this
and
my wife are kind of looking up and and
just exhausted and really not sure what
the future is it might be my entire
adult life i've i've been an
entrepreneur i've started other
businesses um i've never had an exit
like this one um or exit at all the
other ones just kind of
you know failed but this one worked out
um
and now you know we're now we're kind of
looking at each other and i don't have
for the first time
been 17 years of my you know career i
don't have a clear path forward or a
clear vision for really what the future
looks like i'm you know i've got an
opportunity or position that i'm in
right now
um you know i'm working with people that
are way more educated than i am that
that they're leading you know other
business units within this large
organization there's some big stuff that
they're looking to accomplish over the
next several years and it's just
um daunting exhausting and we're trying
to figure out what the future is going
to look like for for you know our family
as it relates to career and even just
you know what that looks like so we're
really struggling with some of that
clarity and
yeah last night i i kind of said well
screw it i'll go ahead and or sorry two
days ago i i said well screw it i'll go
ahead and uh right into john delony
show and kelly called me and so i
appreciate any guidance that you can
provide well number one man
congratulations on your successes and it
sounds like you got hit in the mouth a
few times before that and you got back
off the canvas created something pretty
special that had a lot of value
and
somebody bought it from dude
congratulations that's resilience and
that is grinding it out and there's this
um really ugly picture of a
quote-unquote millionaire that's out
there which is somebody who
sits around and just drinks mai tais all
day and inherits money and it just grows
on trees for them and you're somebody
that ground it out and then you sold it
and you didn't change your life man you
got back in the truck and went back to
work the next day
um so congratulations all around man
that's integrity and its character and
that's that's i'm glad to know there's
folks like you out there dude that's
awesome your inspiration to me and
everybody around me
um thanks
so
lots of of angles we could take here
um
here's where i'd love to start
just because something's a cool
opportunity
and has an opportunity for growth and
has an opportunity to do big things and
huge things and exciting things
doesn't mean that it's right for you
and doesn't mean that you have to do it
you can like an old dating analogy is
you can be absolutely in love with
somebody
and think they are wonderful
and absolutely no they are not the
person you're supposed to marry
those things are not all mutually
exclusive
and same thing when it comes to work
you can really be exciting about the
opportunity and the potential and yada
yada
but you're a guy who builds businesses
from scratch and grinds it out and has a
vision and a mission and you see it
through
and you may not be
fulfilled in the private equity world
where the goal is to make other people
really really really rich
and then to move on like that like a
like an alien ship that just comes in
absorbs all the resources from a planet
and then goes to the next planet right
you know what i mean that may not be
your jam
and that's totally okay but you and i
were taught
that
the job that pays us the most the one
that has the most excitement and the
most growth opportunity that's the job
we have to take that's what's next for
us
and by the way does it suck working at
your own company that you're not the
boss of anymore that can't be fun
yeah it's it's it's been a challenge and
you know
i looked at it just like i tried to look
at everything you know my both my wife
and i are veterans we didn't finish our
college degree we kind of jumped right
into the workforce so i look at this as
an educational opportunity to work for
a large organization take advantage of
the opportunities to learn um
and i think we're having a hard time
just even even making decisions where
we're at what the future is i think one
of the things that's kind of echoed in
my mind i've heard you say it a few
times but
you know you go with you right we've had
over the last
over the last 24 months even just
leading up to it it's been a whirlwind
we've got four kids we have an eleven
and a half year old a nine year old a 19
month old and a six week old
larry lead with that
god almighty dude homie you're fried
fried yeah
okay so hey listen
so
which branch of the military are you in
marine corps
so
there's some mythology around basic
training in the marine corps right
it's for real
right and you learned some stuff about
yourself right it was a good learning
opportunity
that's right yeah would you like to just
keep doing that forever
no no it sucks it's not designed forever
it's not fun correct so tell me if i'm
accurate you how long have you been out
of the military
uh it's been a while man um
probably 15 years
okay so let's backtrack your life a
little bit
you're in the marines
which is
strong to quite strong on the stressor
meter
um you were in right as we were getting
into some of these conflicts
so
okay you're in them and then ta-da we
have a baby
i'm a dad and then i roll out i roll
right into the workforce i try to create
something from nothing
there is successes there's big failures
i'm back in it let's have another kid
and then
whoopsie we'll have another kid and then
super whoopsie do we have another
another kid so now we have a thousand
kids and then the stress of
oh my gosh this business is working
which is a different kind of stress this
thing's actually running and gunning and
creating value
oh my gosh and someone wants to buy it
how long do those conversations were
those a year of conversations and
negotiations
they actually went on for a little over
a year close to two years okay started
having conversations and covid put a
stop to it and so we pivoted real hard
into other
other areas of the business that started
to grow and take traction and
and then they came back and then we had
coveted outbreak we had a team member
pass away we had a lot of stuff happen
in a
in a real short period of time and so
it's the constant
highest of highs lowest of lows
fighter flight
yeah and now we're trying to figure out
what's normal look like and that's
that's really where i know we're
struggling is just
we just live in this
tornado of sorts
trying to figure out what uh
that's why we hesitated on doing
anything rash because we realized that
we recognize that we're in this tornado
so
leaving and going into another tornado
that's not necessarily going to help
unless we can figure out how to how to
live in the world that we're in right
now so i i there's a third option you've
given yourself two
and there's a third option
you've been on fight or flight for 20
years
yeah and there comes a point are you 45
37 37 okay
your body is getting is redlining on you
and it is beeping at you because you
haven't changed the oil in a long time
and you're looking at the metrics part
four kids that are probably pretty
pretty good because they got good
parents you got seven figures in a
payout
you've got good jobs in a in a
corporation now you don't even have
college degrees and you're like yeah
we're kind of running a scam here and
it's awesome
and so you're looking at the metrics i
bet you guys have a nice house
um you've got your metrics that look
good
and it's like looking at the
speedometer my car's still going 100
miles an hour so things are going great
but those lights on the dashboard are
flashing at you brighter and brighter
and brighter so i want to offer you a
third option which is
taking a break for a minute
and that break can look like me and my
wife are gonna go on a three-month
vacation
i mean our three-week vacation a
two-month vacation
hey new company we need a break
we're gonna step out and if they say
well you're fired then then pay us out
we are millionaires pay us out
and my guess is they won't but they
might or maybe a two-week vacation
and you take yeah i don't know you got a
six month a six week old so you all are
in it with that one
but you get babysitters you get someone
to support it and y'all go breathe for
the first time in 20 years
and you can't
um
you know dave ramsey talks a lot about
you know the gazelle intensity the
gazelle running from the lion
there's a reason why our bodies shift
um function away from
wanting to be sexually intimate
wanting to eat well
wanting to
think rationally or being able to think
rationally because the body's just
saying survive survive survive survive
survive
and what i want you guys to do
is to breathe new air
for the first time and
since you were a kid who went into the
marine corps
and then from that place where you guys
have gone
whoo then you can say
what do we want to do now
do we want to start a new business do we
want to invest in something do we want
to just take regular jobs at starbucks
and just relax and find each other for a
year what do we want to do
and starbucks for you two will be every
bit of learning opportunity
as your corporate fancy pants job right
now that's that's that's killing you
because you're not a corporate
fancy-pants iconic guy and you feel
stupid for walking away from it but
that's just not you man
yeah
and so
you can't do the hard work to think
about what do i want
while you're still running for your life
yeah what is it when you think of
just not working for a season do you
have the money to do that
we do yeah we do what would that even
look like for you
it's uh
we've thought we've talked about it um
i mean it's candidly it's terrifying
i don't know why is it because is it
terrifying because of value is it
terrifying because you're scared to look
in the mirror and be peaceful what was
it terrifying
it's probably terrifying just to stop
and
you have to stop and almost have
too much quiet and you'll be forced to
look in the mirror in a sense and
there's
yeah and there's a lot that's happened
over the last you know 20 years to your
point that i've i've just kept running
and running and yeah never really
stopped lots of trauma lots of the so
the the the
in the counseling world we say we call
it leakage
and
you can deal with it on your terms
or your body will deal with it and it
usually is at the most inopportune time
possible
but it will get dealt with in some some
way
here's my recommendation i would love to
see you two not quit anything yet
i'd love to see y'all go get a marriage
counselor not because y'all are
dysfunctional or broken
but somebody who can begin to inject
ideas
and recommendations for
what does
peace look like what are things we work
towards what do we want to do and
they'll just not a counselor like we
need to fix something but y'all got a
six week old y'all are so in it man
how can we even learn how to dream again
how do we even learn what peace is you
haven't had peace in two decades and my
guess is you probably didn't have it
before that either peace may be a whole
new mission for you
and that doesn't mean you don't work
your butt off it doesn't mean you don't
stress and find a new career where you
are grinding and running that's not what
it is
but peace is when you can
whoo smile
when you can have a
series of practices or behaviors where
somebody around you dies that you love
that you can mourn that and grieve that
and then get back on the horse and
grieve it as you're walking
where you cannot work out one day and
know that's gonna be all right
i'm gonna do a couple things for you i'm
gonna send you
my buddy ken coleman's new book from
paycheck to purpose it's the seven steps
on getting clear about what you wanna do
next
i'm gonna send you a free copy of that
book so stay on the line here and i'm
gonna send you two one for you and one
for your wife
um two copies of his new
um
it's an assessment for folks to figure
out i'm at this stage of my life what do
i even want to do next
and it's a good place for you to start
i'm going to send two of those to you
for free also okay
and i want you and your wife to take
those and look at each other and be like
what do we want to do oh my gosh and
here's what i want you to look at i want
you to look at peace
i want you to look at healing i want you
to look at learning what to do next
learning how to look at that dude in the
mirror
those are your new mission those aren't
soft skills those are new
tasks that you need to learn you need
these are hard skills that you need to
learn how to do you didn't know how to
change a tire on a truck in the middle
of desert you had to learn that real
fast you had to learn how to pick up a
50 cal and turn it you'd learn how to do
that real fast you're going to learn how
to do this one now okay these are just
new skills you're going to be curious
you're going to be gentle with yourself
you're going to fail and fall on your
face but you're gritting you get back up
you're going to practice these things
man
and then you've heard me say this a
thousand times i'ma say it a thousand
times more
you and your wife are gonna completely
excavate just like the 9-1-1 site the
the downtown new york you're going to
excavate the whole thing
we built an awesome business we sold it
for seven figures
now what we're in our 30s we can retire
and just move to the mountains
we can create a coffee shop and just
carry coffee around to elderly neighbors
we can create a who a lawn bed who knows
we can do anything
we're going to rebuild something new
we're going to learn new ways to talk to
each other to ourselves
what do we want and i don't know if
you've ever answered that question for
yourself what do i want but now is the
new season we're going to practice
asking yourself that question now does
that sound terrifying or exciting
because it excites me just talking about
it
uh no it does sound exciting and that's
you know we've
we kind of had those conversations
leading up to it as we started dreaming
about okay this is actually happening
and what's the what's the world going to
look like for the the larry family um
you know in the future and
um
and then we just got in it and it's just
like a we've just been stuck on this
train that we used to be the conductors
of and now we're just the passengers so
we're you know we're rolling um so yeah
so
discovering a way to get off that train
and
find out what the future looks like is
exciting that's awesome man all right so
i'm gonna send you these tools so hang
on the line here and kelly will get them
for you and
i want you guys to call a marriage
counselor and you are going to be
a song to a marriage counselor's ears
you're going to call and say hey we're
doing great we want to learn some tools
on how to dream together for the future
it looks like we've been running for 25
years for 20 years non-stop 24 7 365. we
just sold a business
we
we pretended to be corporate people and
we hate it
and we want to know what's next we want
to we want to learn some some new tools
for how to dream
and then i want you all to to lean into
it and by the way you got a six week six
week old a two-year-old
it's it's gonna be bonkers for a few
years and that's okay y'all been through
worse you've been through crazier and
the world is better because larry y'all
two are in it um thank you so so much
for the call we'll be right back on the
dr john de luna show
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back and hey we're
gonna roll out of this show today a
little bit early
we're gonna roll out this one is in my
top 10 of all time and i realize that's
about 100 songs in my top 10 but i don't
care it's my top ten so i can have as
many songs i want my top
like talking to a young person
i got seven best friends i think that
means
they're not your best friend because the
best means the the best one i got seven
best friends whatever dude i got a
hundred songs in my top ten this one's
off
the i and loving you
cd
the avett brothers actually i think it
yeah zion loving you off the everett
brothers record
man these guys are great the song is
called i love in you and it goes like
this
load the car and write the note
grab your bag and grab your coats tell
the ones that need to know
we are headed north
one foot in and one foot back but i
don't pay to live like that so i cut the
ties and i jump the tracks
for never to return
brooklyn brooklyn take me in are you
aware of the shape i'm in
my head they shake my hands they shake
and my head it spins
brooklyn brooklyn take me in we'll see
you soon on the dr john dewey show